in this morning's eye honors were
learning about the critical role sharks
play in maintaining the underwater
ecosystem they are the top predator in
the world's oceans but there is still a
lot we do not know about sharks
some of the biggest questions around how
they mate Mark Phillips recently waded
into that mystery for an up-close and
personal encounter that can only happen
in one place it's like feeling it is a
shark captured by marine scientists Wes
Pratt and Nick Whitney of the New
England Aquarium shark penning is not
something you often get asked to do in
this line of work he's lovely
the shark is an unwilling part of an
annual research study out on the dried
Tortugas
tiny specks of land 70 miles west of Key
West Florida every year like clockwork
sharks gather here for their annual
underwater mating dance and the
scientists gather as well to catch them
it's called extreme site fidelity they
love this place this is a start dating
barb is it's a single spot where sharks
yeah this is the only place in the world
where you can study shark mating
behavior on a reliable basis they've
developed a sly technique moving toward
the sharks as they've got their minds on
something else and netting them it's the
kind of thing you better get right the
first time
nice these are nurse sharks not the most
fearsome species but they can still take
a chunk gonna be when disturbed and this
is the definition of the stirrer
the truth yeah we're we're boy yours but
if somebody has to do it before we
started almost nothing was known about
shark mating behavior this particular
species is a window into that world
white sharks blue sharks hammerheads
all made like this and they're all
threatened landed as bycatch by
fishermen and caught deliberately for
food in some parts of the world without
enough sharks at the top of the food
chain the rest of marine world is out of
whack so yes sharks need our help they
need our understanding they need our
research technology is helping that
research Wes and Nick not only tagged
the Sharks they attached cameras and
instruments that track movement the
devices float to the surface after a few
days revealing whether the animal has
found a partner a little fed up the
Sharks will only stand for all this
handling for so long absolutely some
some are very calm and others are are
less so we have one that every time we
catch is tried to bite me and I've named
it after my sister and if catching them
is tricky try letting them go the trick
is to get him out of here anything I
should be doing so it's back to the
shark singles bar in this day and age
with selfies of course for CBS this
morning I'm Mark Phillips in the Dry
Tortugas know what marine scientists do
I love mark I like Mark's translation to
the science the scientists called it an
extreme site fidelity needs like you
mean a shark dating bar yes